Currently, our setting view
is a list of preferences.
Dan showed you how to create
a custom preference for location.
But what we want to do now, is to
extend that custom preference by adding
a widget to launch the place picker.
However, we only want
to show this widget
when Google Play Services is available.
This way, devices without Play services
can avoid displaying a broken feature.
We already have a check for
Google Play services in main activities
OnCreate because of our GCM integration.
However, we cannot assume that
the user's device will not change
between activity creation and
the active state.
So, the first thing we are going to
do is to perform an additional check
at the moment we display
the location preference,
in case something has gone wonky.
Theoretically, you could move
the existing GCM check from on create to
on resume.
But, these are two different features
that are just powered by the same
service.
And we actually have different
expectations for each feature.
GCM needs to be configured at
the creation of the activity.
But the place picker needs to
be supported each time the user
enters the setting activity.
So we don't want to be checking in on
resume, which means that we should call
is PlayServicesAvailable in our
location edit text preference class.
Note that we aren't handling any
potential recoverable errors this time.
Because, in the middle of
changing a location for
the weather forecast, it would be really
disruptive to direct the user directly
to the Google Play Store for
a potential update.
So, instead, our failure case is that if
the SDK is not immediately available,
we just use the default settings layout.
However, if it is available, then we're
going to add a widget to the location
preference that can launch
the place picker API.
So, now we need to create
a pref current location layout.
This is going to be the icon that we're
going to add to the location preference.
Because we want a simple visual queue,
it's best to use a system icon that
the user will already be familiar with.
All of the Android system icons have
been updated for material design, and
can actually be
downloaded off of GitHub.
You just need to make sure that
you get the right size for
each drawable density
that your app supports.
For Sunshine, that'd be these four.
Because our place picker is
intended to make it easy for
a user to indicate
their current location.
You should retrieve the current
location system icon from the map set.
Then all I need to do is to drop each
resource into its relevant folder.
The layout that we need, then, is
a simple image view of our system icon.
However, our icon is very small.
But, if we wrap it in a frame layout we
can make a larger click space without
having to scale the icon.
All we need to do is reference the ID
of the frame layout instead of
the image view when we
build our click listener.
You'll also want to make sure that all
of your icons are visually aligned.
So to do this you'll want
to set the layout_gravity.
You'll also probably want
icons to match in color.
So just go ahead and
add a color tint in order to get
the icon teal instead of black.
And finally don't forget
your content description.
You'll need to write the string and
strings.XML so
that it can be translated and
then just reference it here.
Now that our layout is ready to go,
we need to set up our OnClickListener.
When the location preference is
created that calls onCreateView.
And then this call back,
we can retrieve our new layout, and
set our OnClickListener.
For now, just go ahead and use a Toast
to test that everything is working.